over 1500
continuing to expand in california the
tesla bot will be real
[Music]
[Applause]
elon musk had a banner year he became
the richest man in the world according
to the bloomberg billionaires index
tesla is on track to increase deliveries
by about 80 percent over those in 2020
according to analyst estimates and
spacex conducted more space launches
this year than its us competitors
how are you spending your time these
days between spacex and tesla it's about
um even between spacex and tesla
it depends on
you know what is the
kind of crisis of the moment in an
interview at the wall street journal's
ceo council summit elon musk shared how
he juggles ambitious projects across
multiple companies all at once i work a
lot i work some days a week and
putting put in
some pretty crazy hours so how did this
year's accomplishments and setbacks
across tesla spacex and starlink prepare
musk for what's to come in 2022.
tesla's made roughly two-thirds of all
the electric cars in the united states
but you know i'm not sure most people
are aware of that tesla kicked off 2021
by posting its first full year of profit
thanks in part to chinese sales however
tesla's also faced increased scrutiny in
china this year and been swept up in the
country's broader crackdown on big tech
the company also made headlines amid
growing concerns over its autopilot
system in august the national highway
traffic safety administration began
investigating tesla's autopilot system
after a series of crashes at emergency
scenes
advanced driver assistance technology
such as tesla's autopilot system has not
been tightly regulated in the u.s to
date but the byte administration has
been taking a closer look tesla didn't
respond to a request for comment but the
company has long said that driving with
autopilot engaged is safer than doing so
without it i think it's safe to say that
scrutiny of advanced driver assistance
systems and automated driving technology
in general is likely to continue
still musk plans to continue upgrading
tesla's advanced driver resistance
technology the car is kind of a robot on
four wheels and and so then well you
know
we could probably take that same
technology and and put it in a humanoid
robot and have that rogue be useful that
next iteration could be the teslabot
which musk unveiled in august it's a
humanoid robot that musk hopes will
perform generic robotic tasks for humans
man starship is a hard hard hard hard
project this is the the biggest rocket
ever made
this year musk also continued to work on
starship which he aims to be the first
fully reusable orbital rocket this is
the rocket that he hopes will take
humans to the moon and mars so we made
the i think the most progressive
reusability that has been done but with
starship we're hoping to make the whole
thing reusable this is uh this is
profound like i said it's different it
is the difference between humanity being
a single planet species and a
multi-planet species it's it's really
that big of a deal in march musk
announced his plan to create a new city
in texas called starbase which he
envisions as the launch site for
starship and in may spacex successfully
landed its starship test vehicle on the
fifth attempt starship heading back to
the land
outside of starship spacex continues to
pave new ground the company launched the
first all-civilian flight to orbit
and it took nasa astronauts to the
international space station for the
second time this year thanks guys and
from endurance it was a great ride
better than we imagined the company also
won an exclusive nasa contract to build
a new lunar lander
starlink is really designed to serve the
the least served starlink musk's
broadband internet service also picked
up pace this year
the bulk of spacex's launches this year
have been related to starlink to getting
those broadband satellites into orbit
this year starlink underwent beta
testing in remote areas of the u.s
check this out starlink in july the
company said it had launched around 1800
satellites and is serving around 140 000
users in over 20 countries just two
instructions point the terminal uh at
the sky and plug it in star link
and start ship sort of fit together
starship is meant to be this enormous
rocket and um you can fit a lot of
starlink
satellites like inside of it to deploy
on december 2nd spacex carried out its
27th mission this year launching nearly
50 starlink satellites into orbit
during his wall street journal interview
musk sidestepped questions about his
future at tesla saying his ceo title is
made up i i changed my title to to
techno king
um
and by the way this is a formal sec
filing it's i'm legally
whatever techno king i just did that as
kind of like a joke because just just to
show that these titles don't mean a lot
days after that interview musk tweeted
possibly in jest that he was thinking of
quitting his jobs title preference aside
musk says he plans to deliver electric
vehicles from two new factories one in
texas and another in germany his other
challenge next year will be launching
the first starship prototype to orbit if
we are successful with this which i i
think we will be but i don't know if
we'll be either in 2022 i hope so
this is a profound revolution in access
to orbit the company has been working to
obtain various licenses and is currently
waiting on an environmental review from
the faa which is expected by the end of
the year starlink also plans to obtain
permission from regulatory agencies to
launch even more satellites next year
spacex has asked the
sort of telecoms regulator in the u.s
for example for permission to
build out a what's called a
constellation sort of a network of of
satellites of about 30 000 of those
devices beyond 2022 musk says he's
excited to introduce the electric
vehicle pickup truck that tesla is
aiming to produce in volume in 2023.
gonna be an incredible product i think
it's it may be our our best product ever
and i think it probably will be between
electric vehicles and rockets the years
ahead may be even more demanding for
musk but could also lead to more banner
moments for the billionaire ceo